welcome guys and girls to another
interview question answer video in
today's video we are going to go over
questions for junior associate level or
for freshers or who are looking for
their first Cloud job they must
absolutely know these uh answers also
for those of you who are experienced I'm
curious uh to see how many of these
questions you folks can correctly answer
for those of you who are new to the
channel my name is Raj I'm a senior
specialist essay at AWS I'm also a
bestselling udem and plural side author
public speaker and guest lecturer all
right with that being said let's get
started question number one name two AWS
services from each area compute storage
and network so for each question if you
want pause the video and think about it
for a minute and then unpause to see the
answer so for compute 2 AWS services are
Lambda and
ec2 uh for storage 2 AWS services are S3
and EBS or elastic block storage and for
Network 2 AWS services are VPC or
virtual private cloud and cloudfront so
think if you can name one more what if
the interviewer asks you three AWS
Services instead of two can you still
answer this uh let me know in the
comment section let me know what
services you are thinking uh next
question how to ensure you do not go
over a certain budget for AWS Bill very
common question lot of you probably
think about this when you start uh
creating a AWS account so the way to do
that is using AWS budgets so in AWS
budgets you could say um I want to pay a
maximum of $20 for this AWS bill for for
uh this month and you could also say if
the projected Bill reaches 80% of my
budget so
$16 uh you can get alerted and you can
also act on it so when you create a
alert uh it can do a SNS topic and you
can fire a Lambda to go shut down ec2
instances kill load balancer Etc you can
also say there are a lot of third partyy
tools in the market such as Cloud Health
which can do similar functionality next
question what is the alternative of
doing everything from console so you go
to console uh you spin up your ec2
create Lambda delete them Etc so what
are the alternative uh so the
alternative is
you can use AWS CLI uh so instead of
going to console and creating everything
you can run AWS CLI commands and create
uh resources destroy update Etc you can
also use AWS SDK and using AWS SDK you
can call AWS apis from your uh code uh
to do this uh AWS provisioning update
delete Etc also going one step further
another way to do that is using Dev hops
uh so you can use some infrastructure as
code such as cloud formation terraform
and run them in a devops pipeline to
provision infrastructure deploy your
code update delete Etc next question
name name some region specific and
Global AWS Services uh so region
specific mean the particular service is
only running in a specific region and
the global means it's not bound to a
region so whenever you think about
region specific service always think of
compute uh because one compute server
can only run in one region uh so the
example could be C2 Lambda elastic
kubernetes service and some of the
global AWS services are IM am cloudfront
so you could tell if a service is
regional or Global uh by going to the
service let's say I am in ec2 and on the
top right you would see a region so that
means this service is a regional service
uh similarly if I go to Lambda on the
top right you still see the region that
means it's a regional service but if I
go to IM am you'll see on the top right
it is global similarly for
cloudfront Global uh so this way you can
you can also explore some of the other
services which are Regional global
global and you can name your own so next
question obviously in interview you're
not going to get all of this but you
there is a high chance you will get
asked some of this so think about it
what is the AWS services for
metrics um so Cloud watch is thews
services for metrics logs so this is a
little tricky one application logs go to
Cloud watch but your infrastructure logs
go to cloud trail so uh if you spin up
ac2 or you go delete ac2 those logs of
who is doing all this stuff go go to
cloud trail but if you have application
running inside that dc2 and the
application is writing logs those logs
will go to cloudwatch so what is the AWS
service for object storage S3 block
storage elastic block storage or EBS so
EBS you can attach with ec2 so uh think
of it like your hard disk your hard disk
that's running on your desktop La laptop
is a block storage as well to the
equivalent Services EBS next one is is
easy VM or virtual machine uh so ec2 is
the virtual machine for AWS
authentication and authorization so this
service is am or identity and access
management uh using IM am uh you can uh
give certain users access to certain
Service as well as what they can do in
that service a no SQL database Dynamo DB
SQL database Amazon Aurora next question
so this one is very popular in the
junior level interview what is your
favorite AWS service and why so I'm
curious let me know in the comment
section what is your favorite AWS
service and why is it your favorite and
I'll take a look and give feedback on
your answers so the why is very
important uh so you should not say for
example I like elastic bin stock because
it is very powerful because it doesn't
answer why you really like it so the
interviewer are going to ask you why do
you think it's powerful what are the
features so yeah put it in the com
comment I'll I'll take a look for some
of the comments and try to give my
feedback next question name some AWS
services that can secure your
application so this is a very very
critical question especially if you are
giving an interview in
Enterprises or high security
organizations such as Financial Services
public sector Etc they will ask you this
question so there are multiple AWS
services so we already talked about one
am identity access management beyond
that uh to secure your data using
encryption you can use uh KMS so using
KMS Keys you can encrypt your data at
rest you have Amazon certificate manager
to store SSL certificate using which you
can encrypt your data at Transit
authentication authorization I am as
well as Cognito you can save user ID
password Incognito and beyond that there
are General security threat for example
dos injection SQL injection attack Etc
so for that you have web application
firewall guard Duty Amazon detective Etc
so study up AWS security services at
least three to four main ones next
question how will you scale your
application running in ec2 kubernetes
Lambda so you folks probably know the
ec21 so ec21 is you do that using Autos
scaling grou group uh using Autos
scaling group you can scale your e2s
based on a threshold for CPU or memory
or some other metrics or you can just
Auto Scale based on some schedule like
9:00 you expect traffic to go up you can
schedule your ec2s kubernetes how do you
scale so you can scale kubernetes pods
using HPA or horizontal pod autoscaler
and you can scale kubernetes work on
nodes using CA or cluster autoscaler
Lambda so that's a trick one there is
nothing to configure for scaling in
Lambda for each of the traffic
connection Lambda will automatically
scale so for each traffic connection
another Lambda instance will come up so
one Lambda instance can only handle uh
one incoming traffic so keep that in
mind so if someone says Hey how do you
configure autoscaling group for Lambda
there is an autoscaling group and don't
say that oh I will configure autoscaling
group for Lambda next question name
three services to run your code in AWS
have you used any of these so these are
definitely compute services so when it
comes to Cloud three main areas are
compute Network and storage and within
this compute is the most important one
because every application you talk about
the heart of the application and all the
business logic is actually uh in the
code which runs in the compute services
so three services you can name ec2
Lambda if you want to go further elastic
kubernetes service or eks ECS elastic
container service we have app Runner we
have light cell Etc have you used any of
these so you should at least use one uh
if you get asked this so definitely try
ec2 and you can try Lambda so kubernetes
is a little bit difficult to do you can
also try app Runner or light cell if
you're interested uh but as long as you
do 2 and Lambda you should be okay next
question what are three ways to run
kubernetes in AWS so kubernetes is super
hot right now so easy answer is eks or
elastic kubernetes service another way
to run is Rosa or red hat open shift for
AWS which run kubernetes with the
opinionated
tools and what is the third option can
you folks think about the third option
if you if you know put it in the comment
if you want so third option is running
self-managed kubernetes on ec2 so you do
not need to use e or Rosa if you don't
want to if you want to manage the
control plan then you can run
self-managed kubernetes just on fel2 so
another question that comes up a lot is
what is AWS region what is availability
Zone and what is point of presence so
you can look up the official AWS
documentation so make sure you study
that because that's also very very
common but I didn't include it I just
wanted to show you this page let me know
if there are other uh interview question
that you want me to answer put them in
the comment section uh please click this
uh like button subscribe and all that
good stuff it really helps the channel
grow all right folks that's it for this
one I'll see you guys and girls in the
next video bye